remember you have to be careful about
using the word conspiracy because as
George Carlin always said where
interests converge no conspiracy is
necessary my friend Russell Brand uh had
a nice little uh a little uh diet tribe
a little diddly let's say on uh how the
truth is concealed and that you don't
need Grand conspiracies to pull things
off the truth is often concealed and
manipulated when various interests
appear to conspire to manage information
in ways that seem advanced AES to the
interests of the powerful remember you
have to be careful about using the word
conspiracy because as George Carlin
always said where interest converge no
conspiracy is necessary these people
went to the same universities and
fraternities they're on the same Boards
of directors they're in the same country
clubs they have like interests they
don't need to call a meeting they know
what's good for them that we should play
more George Carl and stuff so yes you
don't need a grand conspiracy when you
when you look around at the world right
now and you go how is all of this crazy
crazy stuff possible how is it that we
now make it so that if you're not racist
you're actually racist and how is it
that if you have a penis we call you a
girl and a whole bunch of other stuff
and it's like well there has been not a
grand conspiracy per se but a series of
people who have attained power by going
through these institutions and they
don't have to have a secret closed door
meeting to pull off all of the bad ideas
right you don't have to have Mark
Zuckerberg and Bill Gates like get a
group in a scary Castle somewhere in
Transylvania to sit around a table like
when they have like the the evil
Republican meetings in The Simpsons back
in the day you don't really need that
you just need a whole bunch of people
that have run through the same
institutions that kind of think the same
things and play golf together and go to
the same restaurants and country clubs
and their lives are basically the same
and then it's not exactly a conspiracy
when they're pushing all of this crap on
you right and they never want their
children to be learning any of this
stuff of course they want public
education to teach this crap while they
have their children in little pods and
private schools and charter schools and
all of those other
things